[Applause]
[Music]
just in case
okay okay all right shut up just just
get people like at home or like that
went on a long time yes because we told
them before the show this is our 500th
episode people always say what is the
secret to your longevity and I'll tell
you what it is
this country is [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
they asked me if I wanted a balloon drop
I said yeah if it's filled with heroin
but I mean we went on the air in 2003
since then I mean think about weed is
increasingly legal religion is on the
decline and less and unless people are
having children
you're welcome America but enough about
me let's talk about that let's talk
about the coming world war that were on
the brink of of it have you seen this
tensions of course with Iran have been
rising predictably ever since the Iran
nuclear deal was scuttled but Iran
announced this week that they are going
back to enriching uranium Trump was
furious how dare they renege on the deal
that we pulled out of and then yesterday
one of our drones 180 million dollar
plane was shot down and Trump said this
morning that the attack was a tak
against Iran was completely ready to go
of course he can't just bomb Iran or not
bomber and he has to [ __ ] do the
reality show [ __ ] will I bomb Iran
will I call the bomb is back at the last
minute
[Applause]
we'll find out so stay tuned so okay so
he says he's ready to start a war he
treats out
we're cocked and loaded which exactly
it's not a thing it's locked and loaded
cocked and loaded we looked it up is the
name of a gay porn movie
I'm not making this up with the subtitle
a gangbang daddy [ __ ] which is a pretty
good summary of the last two and a half
years I think if a Martian came down
into me what is it like living under
Trump I would say a gangbang to any fun
so I'd like all of you an out there -
hashtag gangbang daddy [ __ ] as a gift to
ourselves for the 500th episode I want
to see gangbang daddy [ __ ] everywhere
but so Trump tweeted yes we're cocked
and loaded ready to go to war and then
he says and I asked how many will die
and the general told me a hundred and
fifty people so 10 minutes before the
strike I stopped it you know like he's
MacGyver cutting the red light I saved
the world again I mean all he does this
guy is create disasters in the last
minute pull back it's government by
auto-erotic asphyxiation as far as
we couldn't have started a war this
morning anyway we don't even have a
Secretary of Defense and Jarrod's taking
a spa day
[Applause]
so he the president you said this kicked
off his 2020 let's pay attention here
this is the big one kicked off his
re-election campaign in Orlando Florida
a couple days ago and he made a very
powerful case against President Hillary
it's the same thing every that's locker
up thank news drain the swamp from 2020
exact same thing is 2016
he's like an old car with the disk stuck
in the CD player no matter how many
buttons you push you're gonna hear I'm
too sexy for my shirt did you see this
Klan rally he was having there his
supporters they have I know we're not
supposed to say that they have goldfish
memory I mean there's like three seconds
after they passed the palm tree they're
like he's talking about the wall he says
it it's beautiful I changed the design
he said this he said I made it stronger
bigger better and cheaper Wow
the balls remember that wall that I
completely pulled out of my ass and
never delivered on well it's better than
ever
they got balls hoe picks his former
communications director testified if we
can call it that before the House
Judiciary Committee refused to answer
anything like anything like literally
where she sat in the room and yet this
is still progress for Democrats at least
the Republicans are showing up in person
to say [ __ ] you even after 500 shows
once in a while there's a clunker
well you never know we're live we're
live live always have been but hope
Hicks she admitted it Sunday she said
she admitted she told white lies for
Trump
boy that's Trump for you even the lies
have to be white
[Applause]
well in a week where all the questions
are about Joe Biden and racism I mean
the proud boys were demonstrating
outside happily marching outside his
rally and we found out this week he
won't put Harriet Tubman on the $20 bill
and that's kind of racist can't even
stand pictures of black people even Klan
members will buy the rice with Uncle Ben
on the box
[Applause]
you